members of the crimean tatar community
gather every friday at this mosque just
outside of ukraine's capital kiev
many of them have been living here since
russia annexed crimea eight years ago
you know we live here but the north
chaos family is still living there he
says people in crimea are struggling
under russian occupation what russia
brings
to the territories where they come they
bring nothing
but
crime
destroying
mother cries
orphaned children we saw this
in crimea we saw this in syria and now
you see
they're trying to do this in ukraine
in the past weeks there have been a
series of attacks on the crimean
peninsula even though ukraine has not
acknowledged its behind them an attack
on the sagi air base destroyed eight
fighter jets from russia's black sea
naval aviation a further drone attack
managed to put russian ground forces on
high alert the attacks in crimea show
ukraine's capacity to strike russian
targets deep behind the front line
president volody mircelensky says he
will fight to recover all occupied
territories including crimea
crimean tatars were deported from the
peninsula by the soviet union in 1944
and thousands of them were forced to
flee in 2014 when russia occupied the
peninsula people here are hoping that
when this war is over they'll be able to
return to their land
even though imam is not from crimea he
says ukrainians need more help to win
the war
ukraine is a free people it's not like
russian people we want to live
independently we don't want to be with
russia
and all we need from actually european
countries it's weapon if we had weapon
we will
fight till the end
the international community has
repeatedly condemned the annexation of
crimea
says the peninsula plays a crucial role
in the conflict in ukraine
russia use crimea as a military base and
president zlansky
says that
750 missile strikes
against ukraine from crimea
as the war goes on ukrainians insist
they're fighting for their freedom
for crimean tatars this is also about
returning to where they belong
perez